hey there ladies and gentleman my name
is Chris waters I'm from a gamespot.com
and here to host the seventh semiannual
Firaxis mega panel thank you all for
coming we have got some great games to
talk about today and some great folks to
talk about them so without further ado
I'm going to pass it down the line and
have these gentlemen introduce
themselves to you I'm Greg Burks I'm the
art director or next come to that way
that was soda Muir the way you said that
good food I'm Jake solemn and I'm the
creative director of Mexico all right so
on the table we've got XCOM too we've
got civilization beyond Earth rising
tide and one's a sequel one's an
expansion pack and there's like our
expansion pack even what people say
anymore expansion probably just suffice
drop the pack just yeah the cool people
say expansion yeah x-pac actually
they're they're different in nature you
know once when you're building a sequel
when you're building an expansion to a
game you kind of have a different
approach you've got a different you know
the audience expectation is different
and maybe the opportunities are
different for development so I'll talk
to will and David first to talk about
rising tide and you know how do you how
did your approach to designing expansion
differ from your poached to designing
another kind of game
well civilization has always had really
excellent expansions we deliver a lot of
value with with our expansions they they
tend to target very specific parts of
our games and when we make an expansion
it's an opportunity for us to step back
take stock and look at how we can make
the experience better how we can deepen
the experience for our audience
rising tide though was a little bit
different we actually looked at what
XCOM did with enemy within which really
changed the entire experience of of XCOM
right it wasn't just the middlegame it
wasn't the late-game as the whole thing
and so rising tide approaches beyond
Earth from that perspective we wanted to
change the entire experience and flush
out what we had set down in the base
game so the new diplomacy system water
gameplay hybrid affinities expanded
quests all of these things are sort of
game wide features so if you if you get
this expansion you're gonna expect to
see a lot of new stuff which we will
look at right now so one of the big
things we're excited to show today the
panel is some of the the things coming
up for hybrid affinities you may
remember affinity as being a sort of a
new idea for beyond Earth big idea that
represents kind of the evolving
futuristic identity of your Civ and how
you're gonna challenge the tackle or
tackle the challenges of the of the
future and it drove a lot of things in
the game but most especially it drove
military drove the way your military
diversified and so the hybrid affinities
were designed to do more or less of the
same things but give you new ways of
tackling old problems and also new
powers that you never saw before in the
game so that when you build your hybrid
army your your military can function in
a way that no civil army ever has and it
becomes a lot more personal more
customized a lot more specific so this
one right we're looking at right now is
the Golem is one of the purity supremacy
crossover unique units the sort of the
ideological angle for purity supremacy
is blending the kind of like a sendin
sea of man idea of purity with sentient
robotics of supremacy but instead of
going all one way or the other the day
adopts sort of like a master servant
the Golem is mr. giant it's a huge
walkin see tool that can block crazed
attacks it's actually cute
very cute around your apartment employer
did this like wall thus portraits know
that block range tax good attack of its
own replacements for your core military
but their augmentations like if you put
this in your army you're definitely
making it sort of a siege army or you're
making it about this or about that the
immortal is one of the sort of mid-level
ones for purity harmony and they take
the the plaintiff once again the purity
emphasis on humanity with harmonies
genetic qualification the engineer super
humans like things that are way beyond
what any human being could do before and
like sort of fuse technology with the
human genome so they have these sort of
like kind of like impossibly
proportioned angelic looking like
flawless looking humans but merged with
their with their gear they're all one
thing they have like bio-organic armor
there there are holistic beings it's
pretty weird so this is like a shock
troop they ignore terrain penalties they
do a lot of other cool things so you
would use this you'd have fewer of these
in your army but each one is
individually more powerful so you're
like focusing the way your army there
aren't refights by by taking
concentrating the enemy's attention on
the immortals who can absorb a lot of
damage while you're so you can whittle
them down
so let's it really shows like what we
wanted to do with the hybrid affinities
was not just taken average the to
deciding supremacy in close period
doesn't
[Music]
take him down a little bit little bit of
both we really looked at the hybrids as
new identities I know them self
equivalent to the original infinities in
how they approach the world this is a
supremacy harmony blend so they're there
I have the the robotics plus the G like
organic organic military to create these
kind of cyborgs pretty much like the the
art angle and sort of attitude that we
took through for this hybrid was imagine
the predator and so all of their units
are kind of based on that like
modifications of what is the predator is
sort of this bioengineered like cyborg
thing and this this unit the a clone is
a sort of an air carrier it's the first
air carrier and SIV and so it supports
aircraft but it also has us like
long-range bombard and it's just like
halfway living things so it's very
resilient the the direction we gave to
the concept art for this thing was
alright it Majan a meet Zeppelin
sure enough oddly enough not the first
time that that phrase has been uttered
at four axes so the yeah the a Kalon is
their ultimate like I said it's a it's a
carrier unit and a long-range
bombardment and
it looks sticky
it's the design
so the the crossover here's the premise
eHarmony is about their their their
power by any means
mechanics why not take both why I have
to pick one or the other we're gonna
we're gonna absorb all the possible
potential power that we so our bird
affinities changed what the original
affinities mean like you can imagine how
these things in your army would change
how would use your core affinity troops
they change how you play every part of
army developments and that's what will
meant when he was talking about enemy
within like even the things that are old
are made new by the addition of the
hybrid affinities and these alternative
options that can change the value or
change the timing or the purpose of even
the original content and of course the
new content stuff like this and I think
the expansions gives us an opportunity
to really question not just our not just
the content that's in the game but also
the the design of our systems from a
very fundamental level so the the water
gameplay for example in the expansion we
we sort of question what the purpose of
a city was cities are these power
centers in your game they're sort of the
engine of your civilization and how do
we we knew we wanted water sit of water
cities but we weren't really sure how we
wanted them to work we wanted them to be
mechanically distinct but not to too
different that you'd have to learn
different sets of rules and I think it
was sort of it coalesced out of the
firmament that they would move we had a
producer that came up with it and QA
came up with it and Dave came up with it
all in the same day we said alright
we're gonna do that we're seeing some
b-roll now of the the lineup of all of
the new hybrid units and as David
mentioned earlier they're not
they're great augmentation here and I
like this dude this is like to the death
tournament with all your - see what
we're watching so one of the things we
were talking about four and agree to
keep coming up I think we've already
showed you breaking part of the fun of
making an expansion is going back to
things that you you treasure a lot about
the base game like the affinities are
really a core mechanic of the base game
they they drive so much progression they
really they are a source of player
investment there's really get into being
like wanting to do
people resonate with these things really
strongly as soon as we get the
opportunity
find ways to make it more right
today everything like like I was saying
for everything that's old is new again
if you do you take the sort of the
landscape that you so carefully laid in
the base game the the power and the fun
of making an expansion is is appending
it so I mean that's work even even the
title of our expansion or like
references to our effort are interested
in like raising the stakes changing the
meaning of everything that used to be
adding so much to the game that nothing
can be taken for granted to get anymore
that's the fun of making an expansion
for a game like sit then that's what
rising tide is you guys put the cities
on the ocean yes yeah that's pretty good
summation right there it takes that base
you know the fact that a city is so
crucial to your identity as a
civilization into your strategy and like
move that around push that thing around
the water like how the design challenges
in sort of prospects of of taking that
fundamental unit and putting it out
there must have been must have been a
big move yeah you can actually see here
in the screenshot sort of the sequence
of moving a city you have to spend
production to do this so moving a city
costs production you can't build another
unit in that city while it's moving it
takes a few turns so it's an interesting
choice do i and this is the only way
that aquatic cities acquire territory so
what do I do I move the city to get more
territory or do I use the city to build
new units and new buildings those kinds
of awesome risk/reward
interesting decision moments are what we
want to create in a game like Civ and
it's cool because you sort of paint your
your culture border now on the water and
you can paint over other peoples which
is pretty neat so it's a it it's a
different kind of territorial
acquisition problem than you you're
having to do on land so yeah and it it
can get pretty it can get pretty
interesting especially in multiplayer
you can kind of brief each other
painting over your your your territory
yeah you had some sort of stunt Wars of
what what different pictures might draw
on the ocean
you don't want to know the pictures that
we've drawn I think we all know will so
when you're sort of looking at an
expansion and talking about breaking the
rules of your game and sort of your
flexing in that way it feels like a real
natural fit for for an expansion that
builds on that game but that question
when viewed doing a sequel becomes a
little different because the sequel is a
different kind of project it's a
different kind of consumer proposition
so when you guys would take take a look
at XCOM 2 and sort of thinking about
what to take what's to leave behind like
how do you how do you come at that as
distinct from you know enemy within yeah
I mean I mean I think the phrase I guess
breaking the rules is a good phrase in
terms of when you're gonna present a
sequel you have to add value I mean you
can't just you can't just improve
everything so you've got to add new
things you got to improve the things
that were there and so breaking the
rules is kind of a good way to think
about it and so you know we have some
new things we have some old favorites
that we wanted to bring along and
improve and along those lines like we
can talk about some of the aliens that
have made the transition to XCOM - like
we have the mute on everybody's beloved
well nobody loves to be loved but
everybody's hated mute on but that's the
second one so yeah the sectoid that's
one that that's a good example of
breaking the rules right because how do
you update the sectoid
you know the the original x-column they
were these cute little pot-bellied gray
things and they were they're pretty cute
and then we kind of update him to be
little claw bird yeah I'm good at words
kawaii bird little crouching things yeah
I can speak for a fee if anybody wants
but yeah I mean then Greg when we start
talking about the sectoid it was one of
those cases of like okay
the sectoid it has to be a sectoid
people expect the sector we love the
sectoid but we have to think about how
we're gonna change them yeah I mean
that's you know
XCOM is built on UFO lore and so you
know the secretary ever buddy has a
little gut great is and so the plane
with that we're you know what it is and
not departing from that but still making
something new is probably one of the
hardest things when we go about making a
new alien and with him in particular
it's it's it's incredibly difficult
because you know he's naked doesn't his
armor so it's awkward the simplest ones
can sometimes be the most difficult but
he's also the place where we usually
start so you know when we started to
approach the second you know we wanted
to blend them with human DNA and we
wanted a lot of cool stuff and so we
made them bigger a little more
formidable but but again that's kind of
a current is the blending with human
data so you can kind of see it in a lot
of our our aliens
yeah China traces through so now he's
taller he's like seven foot tall but
every once in a while he still glitches
back in again we kind of break the rules
but but then we're everyone saw in his
animation he'll glitch back into a
second scamper and so again we're trying
to kind of connect that stuff but kind
of still change it up a little bit right
and then when we push gameplay while as
you want to push him and so obviously
everybody knows that sectoid they're
they mess with your head and so we
obviously keep that but in XCOM to the
sec towards that combined control from
the beginning I think there are a lot of
things but one of my favorite things the
sec towards can do is reanimate corpses
so now they can they can raise
yes kill your friends twice yeah so that
that is always a great moment where it
they can do it too Advent soldiers they
can do it to your enemies that you kill
then they'll they'll raise them they can
do it to your friends who have died on
the battlefield so now of course the key
is if you can take out the sect or then
the zombies will fall but it's it's one
of those cool things that the secretory
can do so mutant again we updated the
mutant a little more slender you know a
little more we actually went backwards
with him you know we actually wanted to
kind of remove some of again to kind of
make him look more like he's blended
with human we kind of would to remove
some of the the crazy bulk of the armor
to kind of make him look a little more
articulated like a human and so we
actually went a little bit backwards
like originally XCOM and made a little
more skin tight green green outfit but
we really wanted to push his scale so he
is he is a lot larger than the wanting
to you as well and a little bit more
muscular yeah and gameplay-wise we
decided to give the mutants now they
have a lot of abilities but one of the
new abilities is their melee attack and
in addition to a melee attack so they
like to angle to get a closer they've
gotten their armored so they can last a
long time so then they like to angle up
close to the soldiers and then they'll
get in there and melee and they also if
you try to melee them it has a counter
attack though they are very dead
yes that was a sequence of brutality
[Music]
like it's better soon oh yeah how do you
improve upon the chrysalids improve in
quotation marks yes and this is one
that's pretty cool because we've talked
a lot about crystalline but nobody's
seen the crystalline right so from X -
so yeah this is gonna be kind of kind of
fun obviously you know you make them a
little more metal even bigger spikes
yeah but with this one you know art was
we really like to look we had this we
just kind of exaggerated a little
yeah we want to you know push the points
I want to make him feel a little more
poisonous and so yeah there is now this
is the great thing about the crystal
that gameplay-wise is that now the
crystal it can burrow into the ground
and become basically invisible so yeah
it's like the worst proximity mine you
can a messy a look at them they're
invisible can't see them and then you
get too close and oh out they come yeah
why would that be scary
alright and then they'll cocoon your
soldiers and out of the cocoon will
spring three crystal eggs so obviously I
have made a good decision
your tears are like candy to me
got a real vicious streak in you guys
right and the berserker and again this
is another one that we we've updated so
she is she's huge we made her we really
wanted to push her she was close to the
mutant before in enemy Unknown and we
wanted her to be her own character and
so she's massive she's really really big
yeah the mouton in in x2 is
significantly bigger and the berserker
is really really big and she is
terrifying absolutely terrifying and you
see the ports on her where she gets all
her juice we always think she just
rolled it out there and again we wanted
to strip her down a little bit in the
sense of you you could see her body you
could see some of the human elements we
wanted to see a little more of the what
was under the armor and so we've kind of
retained the you know her the size
pushed the size but but her skin is
really her armor and those those red
warm areas are more like rhinos skin and
she's got these ports worth you know
she's been broided up or something but
but to really really push her as far as
we could yeah gameplay wise and when
that happens
really far do a lot of damage and the
best thing is devastating punch there
and that's all gameplay so she will do
that to anybody if they get too close so
if the Advent soldiers get too close to
an enraged Berserker she'll take them
out too like she just is in a blind rage
so anything that gets too close to you
can actually play around with her and
get her to attack the the Advent and so
speaking of it so now we're gonna show
wait what's first is it a new one yet no
nothing yet we're new new things are
coming so and this we have shown is the
advent of which there are a couple of so
this is a little too you know and so and
we've only shown we've only shown
shooting we haven't shown actually some
of the coolness of these characters
right and so the mechs you know insult
to injury the Advent they have developed
their own mechs here and they are very
armored up they're very hard to take
down yeah we just wanted to really kind
of kind of make them feel very
mechanical very robotic you know give
them give them give them something that
that removes some of those a lot of the
the Advent stuff that a lot of the
characters are a little softer in some
ways and this one is just a very
different feel yeah complete robot and
and the mechs ability is a micro missile
attack and so the mech can devastate a
wide area take the cover away and then
the Advent support troops can then
attack the XCOM units without cars oh
here we go
so the stun Lancer I love the stun
Lancer so this is a new we've never
shown the stun Lance before so thanks
exclusive the you know stun Lancer is
awesome so she is a complete psycho PNG
all Advent are both genders but so no I
don't mean individuals are both genders
I mean male and female Advent all Advent
can be male and female they're not like
frogs or anything
so is that even true I don't even think
it's I think it's scientifically true
so whatever aliens that's what I know so
yes so the stun Lancer is awesome so
when you see a stud Lancer they are
psychos and they will ignore everything
to melee so we don't want melee just to
be the role of the range of class the
stun Lancer is a sword wielding an
electric sword wielding Advent troopers
so they get close and then they will
ignore everything to get close to a
soldier they'll sacrifice themselves to
do it and they run really far so when
you see when you're already in trouble
and then they have the ability to if
you're lucky stun you a little bit but
if you're unlucky they can knock you
sold unsolvable so yeah they're awesome
this is awesome
how exactly do you mean awesome I don't
mean in theory they're also terrifying
if they're on your side they'd be
awesome mind control them and they're
awesome so so also new stuff is you know
we've talked about we've talked about
the Grenadier but we haven't shown any
any real footage of that and so the
Grenadier is kind of evolution this is
something that we sort of evolved they
this evolved from the heavy but they
have a lot of really cool abilities so
they shoot lots of grenades they can
fire within a cone they do a lot of
really cool abilities where they can
lock down areas so they can you know
shoot this giant cannon in a cone they
can launch a lot of grenades and now we
have all kinds of specialized grenades
lots and lots of different kinds of
grenades that they're gonna going to
dare consume making carry a lot so
I didn't have any yeah and that's good
actually the Grenadiers does a good job
of showing off all the improved
destruction as you can see lots of new
fidelity the strong floor ceilings all
that stuff with a little grenadiers
action that's really grim for us not
setting out to make anyone's life easy
in XCOM - it seems but when you've taken
you know when you're sort of adding
these units and evolving these units one
of the challenges you must run into is
alright we want there to be new stuff we
want people to but we also want it to be
XCOM we also want it to still be
civilization you know how do you the
things that draw people to these games
the Canon of these games you can't you
know you cannot just throw all that out
the window but it's same time you need
to need to give them something new how
do you guys so Canon can be kind of like
limiting in that you know you have to
have certain parameters but at the same
time it it's like what makes your game
your game you know so how do you how do
you deal with that conflict that sort of
struggle well under us the the Canon was
something that we sort of wrestled with
on the base game because we created a
lot of it and then deliberately held it
back and I you know now looking back it
seems like that was obviously a poor
choice because it was it added so much
to the game to bring players into that
story and let them make it their own but
we wanted the story to emerge over time
in the base game so we offer systems
that would bring it out but never got it
Quantic never quite got out far enough
so a lot of the systems that we've added
in rising tide are really about bring
the story out a lot more and one of the
best examples of that is diplomacy in
the way that the leader characters come
to life right the diplomacy system in in
B II was the same as the home ec system
in Civ 5 which is to say you could make
war you can make these you could trade
some resources and that was about it and
one of the things that we realized after
the calculus live and they were playing
was that the psychology of that system
had changed why he didn't work because
we didn't have the historical can in
there to support it so we had to go back
into that system and rebuild it from the
ground up to be more of a platform for
these characters that we created to
express themselves and for that
expression to matter in your strategic
play so the diplomacy system lets you
sort of build your own character over
time the personality of your character
over time which we're seeing here you
can add these these traits to your
character and make the traits better by
spending the diplomatic capital resource
which which is the sort of currency of
diplomacy and then you can also make
these big you can make agreements with
other sibs which is a new way to trade
power and these two these two additions
to diplomacy really make much more
transparent system a more personable
system okay
well of you go see Duncan who's there so
it was a much better as a much better
solution for us to put a game in place
of where of what was there and instead
of five because again we we had these
characters made from whole cloth that we
had to give a platform to express
themselves so that's really the theory
in the so what we wanted to accomplish
with diplomacy yeah I mean
cannon for us is is interesting because
we have you know XCOM is a little more
narrative but and so you know we have
characters we have a story and there's
tension there between making a game of
three playable and making a game that
has you know a compelling story which is
you know x-column it needs a story to
drive it forward and so you know for us
a lot of times obviously that the real
story is about the player and the
players
story that they create and so we'll show
something about that in a second but
something that's more fixed narrative
actually we get to show for the very
first time anywhere is actually there
will be an X column novel
yeah it's I've read it it's great it's
by Greg Keyes you wrote the Briar King
and it's what it does is it's sort of
it's a prequel to home XCOM to and so
it's it sort of sits between them and
it's cool it's got a lot of old
characters and new characters and
there's something really neat about
seeing characters you know and and their
their fictionalized and it was really
cool if you don't push 20 years in the
future like XCOM 2 is it allows us to
take some freedoms that you know a game
that picks up right after the last one
it would be a little difficult you know
I think I think we've had more openness
because of that difference in time you
know in the game yeah I mean we don't
want
excellence isn't to say that the next
time won't at points be linear but you
know we want to make XCOM we love exhale
we want to make as many x times as we
can and so for us to untracked a
narrative been sort of instead focused
on the player experience and have a lot
of continuity but not necessarily be a
linear every time I think that was
something we wanted to try and it was
such a common thing I mean so many
people lost you yes you know so and yeah
and I always say and I for myself too in
the universe so in the universe is where
every time you play a game of X I always
think it's a you know you're spinning
off an alternate universe and the
universe is that you won XCOM to never
happened like I don't want to take that
away from people and I don't think that
the games that I want XCOM to ever
needed to happen but the games that I
lost exhale on to is just sort of a
chance to go back and say what would
have happened in that world that I did
lose and the council did shut down so
again what we talk about when we talk
about story what really drives us is not
necessarily the linear narrative
x-column but actually the character
story so this next feature is something
I'm very very excited
about this is probably my favorite
feature so what you can do is there's a
I did not give myself that nickname um
so the character pool is something that
exists outside of any single single
player game in which any character that
you customize is added to the pool and
then can be shared with other people can
they will come back into your
single-player games if you want them to
and it's not just soldiers you can mark
up characters to say this is going to be
a scientist in my games this one's the
VIP this one's a bad person that I'm
gonna have neutralized missions so if
you have anybody you don't particularly
like right it's uncanny but the idea is
that you know we have launched the
customization way way way further than
we did in enemy Unknown and what we want
to do is allow you to do that and you
can do it in your single-player games
that's a cool thing too is any
characters you're customizing a
single-player game you can very quickly
then you see the button down there save
the character pool so if you start
becoming attached to a soldier and
you've done some customization work you
just hit save to character pool and
they're now in your pool forever and
they won't show up as recruits in future
games if you want them to and the great
thing is that because you can share your
pool so you can export from your
character pools and you can share with
your friends so if somebody makes you
know I don't
eighty WWE or something like that or
Star Wars characters whatever it is you
can share those with each other you can
just import them into your character
pool and it's a really cool way for
people to save the characters have
customized dictate what scientists and
engineers are in their game and it's you
know I've done this and so if you you
know you make I've made my wife a
scientist and so she'll show up in my
game as I'm playing and let me tell you
something when someone you love shows up
as a mission reward and you're trying to
choose what to do
it becomes extra difficult to be like no
no I'm not gonna rescue her I'll go over
here and just do this and I need to get
some supplies well my wife is in an
Advent Jail
but then you rescue them and they're
real staff on the Avenger and so it's
everything it's VIPs it's bad guys it's
soldiers and you can share so that's
something and say this is a great dev
tool to like everybody on the team is is
in the character that's right that's
right and you know we'll go in and every
once in while I'm a I'm a make par pink
or something and you know save him a
little funny and quickly plays and
discovers that he's been changed yeah
and yeah every that right now we're
playing with a character pool which is
all the devs and so it's funny because
you'll see the character pool is very
aspirational like
you'll see the way that people view
themselves and you like aspiring to a
sweet stash right Dave is a weed dealer
who hangs out behind a strip club right
make them my unseemly and NPC I guess I
turned into a crystalline that's right
yeah so the character pool is is that's
something that we were very excited very
excited to share with everybody and I'm
very excited to see all the pools that
get made and shared with everybody
oh the monocle there we go
yeah it's we have brow rings we even
yeah but face jewelry we have all kinds
of we have all kinds of customization so
if there's no way we could show it all
so it's it's really cool and if you
customized that much that's why I had to
let you go save all that stuff so no
that's what's weird is it character is
like I think I think I put things on
their luggage and the monocle was like a
joke I was like I'll come back to this
in two years and come up with something
better but they went so fast they're
like the monocle said I'm like the
monocle
that was kind of a joke but all right
I'm surprised at how many gameplay
decisions get made like that yes wait we
didn't take that out we showed and once
it's in write get take it up yeah so he
you know change all sorts of crazy stuff
yes future yep
it's nice to be able to have that you
know all that time you spend in that
character development because I'm sure
we have all spent a lot of time crafting
these characters to then have it be safe
have it you know be able to come back
around not just one off for the I mean
it actually does serve that purpose if
you make your friends you make your
family members or you can make yourself
and send it to your friends and family
members but the idea is that all that
time you spend as long as you hit the
safe to character pool button will not
be wasted because you'll be like oh they
died as a rookie but at least you know
they're saved and they can appear in
your future games very cool
[Music]
and we got one more because because we
love packs we have one more treat for
you guys just real quick we're gonna
show you now
three days we have an urgent matter to
address as he formerly known as Seattle
while our efforts to recruit new
operatives their improvement unusually
successful but the new enemy now stalks
the region transmitting footage now
you may now resume your tactical
simulation training that yeah that is
that is something we call the faceless
that is a new yeah that's something also
brand-new that we've never said any more
before that he's called the faceless so
so rising tide is going to be out
October 9th
you can pre-order it now next com2 yeah
the RIP nip 2016 also you can you can
buy tickets for for AXA con who did
anybody in the audience come to fracks
con last year one person two people all
right three people this is a really
great opportunity everybody
lots of people at the studio go to
fracks a con to interact with our fans
you get to play games before we release
them lots of cool swag Sid's going to be
there it's a really cool thing if you
can get tickets they're on sale right
now and want to come to Baltimore and
hang out with us and love to have you
there that's October 3rd also my
birthday so please come celebrate me so
throwing yourself a convention that's
right it's nice party very cool and if
you folks want to get a look at all the
stuff you saw here in the panel today
the video is gonna be going up on
gamespot in the next week or two you can
follow me on twitter at CT wi tter us to
find out when that happens and of course
follow XCOM and sieve on all the social
medias all right gentlemen thank you so
much for this look at your games for
delving into it with us
gonna be an exciting few months for
Firaxis fans enjoy your your bonus packs
items here and have a great show